-False.
-Wait, wait, wait.
Hold on a second.
You know that?
You think there's -- No,
that's got to be false, right?
-It's false.
-Wait, but -- Wait.
I don't want to be --
I don't want my mind blown.
-Yes, you do.
-Are you sure?
I am absolutely positive.
-Alright,
are you locking it in?
-I remember this.
-Okay.
-The answer may surprise you.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Dwayne and I are about to play
a new game
called "Blow Your Mind."
♪♪
-♪ Blow Your Mind ♪
-Questlove!
Do you want to explain
how the game works?
[ Laughter ]
-Of course, Jimmy.
In this game,
I will read each of you
a mind-blowing fact.
And you must decide
if that fact is true or false.
If you choose wrong,
we will blow your mind.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You will be blasted in the face
from the tube in front of you.
Make the right choice,
and your opponent
gets their mind blown.
-Alright, okay, I gotcha.
[ Clears throat ]
-The first fact is for Dwayne.
-Yeah.
-True or false...
-False.
-Wait, wait, wait.
Hold on a second.
You know that?
You think there's -- No,
that's got to be false, right?
-It's false.
-Wait, but -- Wait.
I don't want to be --
I don't want my mind blown.
-Yes, you do.
-Are you sure?
I am absolutely positive.
-Alright,
are you locking it in?
-I remember this.
-Okay.
-The answer may surprise you.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-[ Laughs ]
-It's true!
Can we see that again
in slow motion?
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-Nice.
-There are more stars --
-The next fact
is for you, Jimmy.
-Okay, yeah, yeah.
If laid out end to end...
-[ Groans ]
-Truth or a lie?
-[ Laughs ]
No, you could be acting
like it's so obvious.
-Ahh!
-I know, 'cause I think
that it's obvious.
I think I've heard this,
that, yes, it is, the small --
Oh, wait.
Or is it the large intestine?
-Yeah.
-The small intestine.
-I think this is
a trick question.
First of all,
I've never looked cooler.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Uh, I think I would say
that is -- that is, uh, true.
It's longer
than a football field.
-Is he correct?
-The answer might --
-The answer may surprise you.
-Yeah. There.
Yes.
-Ahh.
-That is a lie.
Let's see that mind blowing
again in slow motion.
-Yeah!
-What the heck was that?!
-Lettuce in the mouth!
-Wait. You didn't get lettuce!
Why do I get --
You got, like, conf--
You got, like, Fruity Pebbles!
You got Fruity Pebbles.
I got some old salad.
-I got cotton.
-What the heck was that?
-There's bacteria on that salad.
-Dwayne.
-Oh, my God!
-Yes.
-You're up next.
-Alright.
-Fact or fiction?
Truth or false?
-This is a joke.
Look how big my hand is.
[ Laughter ]
-That is completely,
unequivocally false.
-Yeah, I agree.
-The answer --
-Answer may surprise you, yeah.
-Yes. The answer
may surprise you.
-Ohh.
[ Buzzer ]
-It's true. Can we see that
again in slow motion, please?
-What'd you get in that?
-That was harder.
-That was hail.
You got hit with hail.
Oh, hail, no!
You got hailed.
-I got hail no.
-Alright.
-This next fact is for Jimmy.
-Wait. Wait.
-Does that -- Wait.
So there's only two escalators
in the state of Wyoming?
-Yeah, apparently.
-Oh, okay.
-You want to get another --
-No, I'm good, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Truth or a lie?
-[ Imitating flushing ]
I'm --
Toilet, not urinals, right?
Toilets.
-Toilet.
-[ Imitating flushing ]
Was that E-flat?
♪ You give me that note,
Is that an E-flat? ♪
-♪ That's E-flat, yes, it is ♪
-[ Imitating flushing ]
I think, if so,
that's a total coincidence.
I will say
that is absolutely false.
-Alright.
-Is he correct?
-Just -- Ohh!
[ Buzzer ]
-Yeah! [ Laughs ]
-You were supposed to say --
You were supposed to say,
"The answer may surprise you."
-Nah. Let's see that mind
blowing again in slow motion.
-You're supposed to say,
"The answer may surpr--"
What was that?
-Yeah!
-I don't know what that was.
It was like a Ziploc bag
of kidneys or something.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Thunder crashes ]
-Excuse me.
-Oh, yeah. Oh. E-flat.
-That sound means it's time
for the final question.
It's a simple
yes-or-no question.
And it comes with a twist.
If you answer incorrectly,
both of your minds
will be blown.
-Dwayne.
-Okay.
-The question goes to you.
-Oh, gosh!
-[ Laughs ]
I know.
I better do the same thing.
-Just do the same --
We're not gonna get this right.
-Alright. 'Cause this
is extremely debatable.
-Yeah, I know.
I know. It is. Yeah.
-My answer --
is a hot dog a sandwich?
Yes, it is a sandwich.
[ Audience booing ]
-Oh, boo!
-Are you sure?
[ Laughter ]
-A hot dog is a sandwich.
It's got meat and two --
and two pieces of bread!
-Look at you yelling that.
Or debating is -- Alright.
-Is the answer correct?
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
-You are wrong.
A hot dog is not a sandwich.
Let's see the shock again
in slow motion.
-There you go. Look at this.
Blam! Right there.
Ooh.
Got a little mustache there.
I had, like, a --
"Time to make the doughnuts."
-You look so cool.
-Thank you. You, too.
Dwayne Johnson
is the winner, everybody!
We're about to face off in
a game called "Blow Your Mind."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Blow Your Mind ♪
-Now, if I win...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughing ] If I win...
you'll wear this
for two days straight.
-I'll let you go
to Duane Reade's,
get some super glue.
Yeah. Then baow!
-[ Laughs ]
Questlove, would you like to
explain how the game works?
[ Air rushing ]
-Yes, Jimmy.
In this game, I'll read
each of you a mind-blowing fact.
And if you decide
the fact is true or false,
if you choose wrong,
we will blow...your...mind.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you will be blasted
in the face
from the tube in front of you.
Make the right choice,
and your opponent
gets their mind blown.
The first fact...
[ As Shaq ] ...is for Shaq.
[ Normal voice ]
Shaq, true or false.
True or false?
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, really? Come on.
I...
-Cat.
-Princeton.
-Communications
Analytical Tool. True.
-Shaq, the answer
may surprise you.
♪♪
[ Ding! ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's true!
Can we please see that again
in slow motion?
-What the heck was that?
Oh, my gosh! Geez!
Wow! Alright. Here we go.
-So, Jimmy.
-What?
-Jimmy, the next fact
is for you.
-Alright.
-True or false...
True or false?
-Your entire career? No!
I feel like -- I mean --
Foul shots wasn't
your thing, right?
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
But the other -- the other --
[ Laughs ] Softball there.
But everything else,
you dominated.
I think that you've
done everything.
I don't think that there's
something that you haven't done
at least more than once.
So I'm going to say --
Gosh. Only one three-pointer?
There's no way!
Dude, you --
-Get to the point.
-You play --
-What's your answer, Jimmy?
-Alright. I'm gonna say --
I'm gonna say the answer
is, uh, uh, false.
-Jimmy, the answer...
may surprise you.
-May surprise you.
Yeah, thank you.
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
-Jimmy, it's true.
Can we please see that again
in slow motion?
-What was that?
I guess it --
I don't know what that was.
-That's mustaches.
-Mustaches?
-Yeah.
Let me see it.
Ugh! Real mustaches!
-Shaq, you're up next.
Shaq...
[ Laughter ]
True or false...
True or false?
-Since I always watch
"Shark Week,"
I've never seen that fact
on "Shark Week."
-Well, you ever see
"Shark Tank"?
-Yes, I've seen "Shark Tank."
-You ever seen anyone bite
anyone on "Shark Tank"?
-No, I've never seen
Mark Cuban bite anybody.
I'm going to go with false.
-Shaq, the answer
may surprise you.
♪♪
-[ Jimmy laughs ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
-It's true.
Can we please see that again
in slow motion?
-What was that?
-It was something --
What'd you get hit with?
Salad. It was lettuce.
There's something --
It went in your goggles.
One went in your goggles.
Yeah, sorry about that.
That's lettuce.
Uh...
Don't eat that. No, it's not --
No, it's marijuana.
Sorry. It's marijuana.
Just kidding. Just kidding.
Alright.
-The next fact
is for you, Jimmy.
-Yeah, okay.
-Jimmy, true or false...
True or false?
-Hmm.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ] I don't know.
I've never tried this.
[ Laughs ]
I don't know, man.
Physically impossible
to lick your own --
Well, what if you're,
like, Gene Simmons?
He's got, like, a long tongue.
You know? Or --
It's physically impossible
to lick your own elbow.
This is kind of a --
Come on, man.
I think that is true.
It is physically impossible
to lick your own elbow.
-Hey, Jimmy,
the answer may surprise you.
-The answer may surprise you.
-Yeah.
-Aah!
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
-It's false.
[ Thunder crashes ]
Okay, so, it's time
for the final question.
And it comes with a twist.
Excuse me.
If you answer incorrectly,
both of your minds
will be blown.
Shaq, this conundrum is for you.
[ Audience oohs ]
-Come on, dude. Come on, dude.
"Is it pronounced 'gif'
or 'jif'?"
-I know you're not talking
about the peanut butter.
[ Laughter ]
So you must be talking
about technology.
I'm going to go with --
Black people say gif.
It's gif.
-Okay.
So that's your answer.
Uh, the answer actually
may surprise you, Shaq,
believe it or not.
♪♪
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
You are wrong.
It is pronounced jif.
-Jif. Oh, my goodness.
Shaquille O'Neal, everybody!
The champion.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You won. You're the champion.
You won.